citizens of the reject Nation it is time
to dive into my Adventures of Superman
part 3 for us which is episodes 8 9 and
the finale we are going to be watching
the finale in roughly real time for the
first time we caught up and we are here
John how you feeling I am so groovy koi
I wore my cryptozoology t-shirt in honor
of my man Jimmy Olsen I worked by
Because the Internet shirt because we're
watching it on the internet yes that's
the correlation we're both uh
thematically appropriate yeah we're both
going tangential today also this
Superman definitely a fan of Donald
Gluck oh definitely if he has any taste
this man knows his childish game being
now and speaking of taste you have taste
for watching this video and I'd like you
to leave that taste in the comment below
and let us know what you want us to dive
into next let us know your taste your
goals your Acquisitions what you
acquiesce what you have been seeking for
us to experience and hit that like give
us validation validate us with your
thumbs and your pointer fingers also hit
that subscription Bell and hit any other
buttons except the x that you want to
hit is there still an X in the screen
they it's like a red circle now might
it's both and as ever the fine folks at
prepper are prepping they're prepping so
good they're prepping us for victory
they're prepping us to deliver this to
you and they're prepping a nice salad I
imagine so thanks to prepper for making
us look nutritious and smart we
appreciate you and if you want to watch
us watch the entirety of this front back
beginning to end with our resting faces
then head on over to patreon to become a
super sexy reject where you can see this
in its entire tee without further Ado
let's watch a part one
of two of my Avengers is Superman three
two one
[Music]
what's going on
what
it's a team up
and you're all on task force x I hope
you like it you destroyed property and
endangered citizens oh we find out who
he is you will repay your debt to
society still thinking Lane I'm sticking
with it okay I'll stick with it I'm
gonna go Deadshot still I don't know why
it's got a feeling
I think I think he's either
Deadshot the one is an old I mean you
know he's not one he's he's clearly in a
position of power but he's not as fit as
he once was I'll take it I like that I
think it'd be interesting to have
someone that like is a different type
but still working with Waller I'm for it
after this operation Superman will cease
to be a problem
The General
huh It's gotta be overwhelming cannot
imagine Superman
Superman there was almost a bulldozer
accident I stopped it I have super
hearings this is so going on flamebird
manic Superman I can hear uh uh uh cat
and tree he has not slept I can hear
everyone Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy
[Music]
you've been sleeping much buddy not for
a few days
that's not important because I heard him
the general he's in the city and he's
planning something I can't stop until I
find him damn
wow how did he get the omnipresent
reigning cherry pie flew out right as
she came in you put him in the
ventilation of the entire building oh
that's cute oh what's excessive
[Music]
I need you to assist Our Guest editorial
right
Porter who broke the queen industry's
inheritance Scandal Who took down the
falcones Falcone name check and queen
but she's thinking of leaving the Gotham
Gazette I want her here winning us
Awards I need you to do whatever you can
to keep her happy we need her for more
Batman Easter eggs we need DC World
expansion and Exposition and we're
writing about the number one greatest
danger to Metropolis
Superman of course
on a crime spree downtown intergang The
Invisible Man he's the one the General's
looking for but he's invisible
quite ironic such a nice boy and he
carries my groceries
flip Johnson yeah
news kit and what is your relationship
to Superman he saved Flip's life and he
let Patty interview him for the news kit
newspaper
people
sorry I don't have much time an
invisible man is running around and I
think he's connected to the general whoa
bird watchers say an invisible force
broke the window at Morrison's pawn shop
less than a minute ago whoa let's go
meet my final interview subject it's a
general man's no hero he's the end of
the world
have we met him is that isn't that Alex
Alex from the first Yeah Yeah from the
uh I think that's Lex
oh boy
oh
mazotec and put thousands out of work I
see a level of Destruction no human
could ever achieve what about your boss
if you really wanted to hurt us what
could we do about it
no just him having a bad day could spell
the end for us Batman metaphor yeah
it needs a little push
you can't publish this you want to be
number one you don't get there by
writing fluff you go for blood that's
something fairy never understood yeah
but you don't just only go for blood she
works on the internet I mean
you got one bad take and a bunch of you
know like do well on Twitter yeah you
can't fit Nuance into a headline
we'll talk
oh boy
whoa whoa
heck you could have killed someone no
Invisible Man the worst day for this
right now I need to find the general
before well maybe you shouldn't
right now
take a break from being Superman and try
being normal
Spider-Man to this walk away from the
costume yeah put it in a trash can
ceremoniously
I need to save my sister they grabbed us
after you ruined our bank job I got away
but they got Siobhan and Albert they
took him into an underground facility
with their other prisoners
they're moving everyone out today
to some new location if I don't break
them out now I might never find them
again what Easter egg City are they
being moved to
if you show me where they're holding her
I'll help you get them back damn what a
guy it's an interesting little plot line
oh cool Tech yeah we're too late no
we're not yeah not for me
hold on
[Music]
oh boss fight in the air no
I think you could ruin my life without
any consequences no self-awareness my
guy no
but now he looks like a mix of like
Frieza and boo yeah I like this parasite
it's got a little bit of uh
Gengar in there too Pokemon all the
animes yeah yeah
jeez We Can't Stop Clark but we can stop
Vicky we'll talk to Perry whoa did you
see what Vicki Vale just posted
[Laughter]
oh boy
editor-in-chief she used us to get
promoted This is Gonna Hurt Clark
Lois this is gonna hurt Clark this is
hurting Clark right now bibo 87 was the
name
bibo lives I hope we get yes
oh I hope this restaurant's doing well
nice grip on the physics too
no no
[Music]
ah jeez
nice that was sick Jack Queen plus this
choreography this is like one of my
favorite Supermans yeah I love this it
feels like fresh but classic yeah
impressively yeah and he's got that
right every man kind of quality
I'm dead oh
[Music]
God Stand Down Ivo they're gonna blow
his head up
[Applause]
done when I say you're done either I'll
tell you when you've had enough why are
you doing this because you are no hero
you are the end of the world no I I I
only want to shut him up
people keep saying that you wonder at
the end of the world it's very specific
maybe somebody with multiversal
knowledge
maybe it wasn't all just fun and games
with Mr mixy
really impressed with the pacing the
overall style like you said classic but
new just impressive stuff yeah and like
again they're bite-sized but they're
also really nicely rounded they work
individually and as the Vicky Vale
episode but it's a part one of two it's
got a whole Arc we have the whole
journey starting the next one and we're
back yeah anything on flame bird nothing
he disappeared off the face of the Earth
which is why we're here yes
the real heroes big words spot the
walkie-talkies Gabby made missing
posters even even Patty is helping Patty
stepping up even Patty we'll find him
and everything will be okay you'll see
MVP of the Shelf yeah go stranger things
kids
find that secret laboratory
season two she's got mine
secretly that's Lucas's sister
she's credited D yeah
you're not going to punch your way out
of this one Superman now I need dates
and numbers what I'm lonely
who's your black book yeah
I've lived on earth my whole life stop
lying I was there on zero day and so
were you what an unidentified flying
object broke through the atmosphere but
where are you here taking a nap come on
I'll be home soon I can't believe you
whoa uh Hey Mandy don't Mandy me damn it
is him get your head in the game you
know one day I'm not gonna be around to
pull you out of trouble
what do you mean you've got a whole
series coming up in and out of
continuity yeah
[Music]
that's does not look like it means hope
wild nope
is this like a Zod is this it looks
Oddish yeah
whoa this definitely looks like their
Tech yeah yeah cool design work so the
American government retrofitting
Kryptonian Tech that tracks
I like the motion blur and the edge of
frame stuff they're doing uh the like
lensing that they're putting on the
glassing effect
that was intense yeah
laughs
[Music]
then you showed up passing yourself off
as a hero so you are going to tell me
everything you know who are you and why
are you on Earth who is your dad dude
what does he do scientist
you know I'm something of a scientist
Mrs Omega attacked and when it seems
like we finally have the answers in our
grasp what if we're wrong oh
and if he's compromised your commitment
then it's time to get rid of him we need
information more than revenge
we're keeping Superman alive for
questioning it's my call not yours
dismissed he'll be following for long
oh boy
hey
[Music]
still want to take down Superman
wow
she hit you're kind of they're gonna
need Superman now yeah there you go
these two to deal with oh the only
reason you won last time is because you
cheated you just hurt me I hurt
Wilson Waller Code Orange
code oh Ivo
stand down he's mine
yeah buddy
[Music]
oh boy is that a freaking Kaiju
dammit inter gang and live wire and the
rest of them I like the stakes building
up enough to make a finale work for
Superman yeah they do a good job
bye bye Black Ops
no no agent slayed Wilson
I mean Ryden
that is how he will bond with Sam
[Music]
's crazy
that is a lot of parasite leave me
Clubhouse
remember when you asked me who I was I'm
a weapon I'm an alien Invader sent to
kill you all you're not a weapon you're
a person you'll never be Ultraman
this guy though
oh damn it is a polask I do like the
centipede version of Godzilla whoa
it looks dinked
yeah it does
it looks very dank very like very dank
and moist and just yeah a crab that sat
out too a lot of mucus on him yeah Clark
you
get him in your condition and he's just
getting stronger with every building he
drains and
people are getting hurt Lois
I have to try oh
[Music]
is there a point where it just explodes
it would be nice if we have fun
subversion
Superman shows up just in time
like Men in Black
oh yeah the heat vision come on I was
gonna say heat his energy but maybe this
energy doesn't feed him we have
why haven't I haven't go live Jimmy
but my real name is Jimmy Olsen play
bird face reveal
reporter for the daily
planets is under attack Superman now
defending US based Ivo people have told
you to fear super Superman because he's
different from us because we want to
punish those who don't look or act like
us this guy's a flame bird watcher
ironically yeah it's our turn Metropolis
so please turn off your power shut off
your buildings Breakers your generators
yes Superman has saved this city over
and over again it's time for us to save
Superman
yeah who's got you yeah Spider-Man too
come on Superman
turn off the light
trigger the inside it's gonna work
[Music]
dude your whole skill set is cheating I
won't let you hurt the people of this
city yeah
oh
dude I just want to strangle this guy
you chose to be a monster Ivo then what
does that mean
cool pull him out pull them out don't
you read the paper oh
oh damn cool nice
I'm Superman
yeah it's Dustin done and dusted out of
this world get used to me being right
here because I am never letting you go
again buddy
oh
The Daily Planet
he's Lex Luthor yeah so don't ever worry
me like that again Smallville
I love you and
[Music]
all these cuties
[Applause]
I ship them yeah
look at that
wing beautiful
no oh no no James our superiors have
been displeased at your failure to take
lethal Action Against The Invader at the
cost of Civilian lives and what do you
call what happened today the
your
you are no longer head of task force
Acts I am whoa from now on we're taking
a different track in regards to Superman
ivo's last invention the Omega cannon
good should weaken the alien enough for
you to carry out your new Mission track
down and terminate Superman ugh
how cruel
jeepers
I wonder if that's gonna be the finale
it could be I mean yeah it seems like
and then maybe that's where the truth
who is he of you get Alex who's that guy
yeah
do we see bibo in person do we get to
that I mean that really matters do they
eat a bevos that's the post credits last
picture on the credits will be them
eating yeah the Polaroid is of bippos
they zoom out
shows great yeah all right rolling in
the episode the finale here we go finale
so good so far
this sticks The Landing
the whole ranking of the DC yeah we
gotta throw it in there somewhere it's
our first show that's full
[Music]
oh no
oh
effectively ominous yeah it's a super
nightmare
post-traumatic Superman disorder this s
stands for sad
[Music]
oh no no no no no no if I'll have that
nightmare but as a Kryptonian yeah I'll
never be like you and if you come to
Earth again I'll be here to stop you
about that
[Music]
oh
damn they got me I didn't think we're
getting English they got me I'm like is
it reacting to to Clark's language
acclimate I do wonder if we get a season
two if we get more Krypton okay good
season two I would love a season two
thank you so much for hosting me and my
dad for Thanksgiving I'm bringing yams
this year it's gonna be yam-tastic it
might be Lane let's do it I think it's
General Lane
a statue of parasite
I need your help finding the general the
guy who kidnapped and then tried to kill
you
your father yeah you're sure he hasn't
seen the terrifying evil Superman data
sphere no I'm seeing that it would
destroy him
just hate secrets we said no words
characters are always saying that you
three have brought me more trouble than
every other intern we've ever had
know how we deal with this type of
behavior The Daily Planet whippings
City safe Superman by Lois Lane Clark
Kenton Jimmy
so the only thing to do was to make a
reporter yes oh that was fair that's
Barry White there you go that's
beautiful
you guys are the new Team Rocket cute
cute cute
it's true she gets Pulitzer
oh I love this Lane go have a Happy
Thanksgiving
good I need you to stay awesome we need
to talk about flame bird
I want to put it on The Daily Planet
YouTube channel I need those views well
you know that Clark's the one who saved
the city and he couldn't have done it
without you Clark peel potatoes I'm in
the turkey Zone
you unlock this door with the baster of
imagination pocket
after his powers showed up Clark was so
scared of hurting someone that
himself at a distance
but now he has you with him
thank you for helping us avoid a bright
burn
single-handed lead now irresponsible so
I hope you love them
Dad's here reporting for Duty come on
what's the Worst That Could Happen he's
rude to you and Ma and PAW and then
everybody hates me hey
nothing can change the way I feel about
you not even your dad who tried to kill
me
my dad
nice to meet you Mr Lane please call me
General Lane oh boy
have we met before nope just have one of
those faces
how do you
spend your time
jeez she's smart hard-working and
successful she's Elaine it's what we
expect I am not oppressed what are you
doing with your life Kent Clark does a
lot just the other day he saved the
entire store
whoa at the store ma we should help in
the kitchen no do not leave
be right back
Mom let's say you had an enemy I'd turn
him into a friend but if someone really
hated you you can't hate your
girlfriend's father Clark oh boy no
matter what he says about your perfect
son
go throw hands mom
Sean will Martha means Mrs Kent said
something about success I had my first
article published
ta-da already made the ball fan of
Superman everyone loves him not everyone
you haven't read it have you I've been
busy I can't read I'm trying to kill
Superman I wish I could remember where
I've seen you before applied sciences
just a journalism degree sir do you
always wear glasses
Lois's dad is the general the general
who tried to kill me what
I love this I hate Lois she is as sweet
as apple pie but that man is
a lot sure what a great final episode
after the action he gets dip it's like
this level don't tell anyone Jimmy but
this turkey is refusing to come to temp
Jimmy's got the solution flame bird
knows oh everyone you have something to
tell me I don't know who you are
how about awkward this all is Clark you
are going to tell Lois about her dad
then you are both going to thank me for
my emotional maturity and for bringing
your stuff which you laughed at the
planet
now no no
what is this
they waste no time this show just moves
yeah
[Music]
this isn't you I can't
oh
no oh
no this is bad
what's going on the rock
[Music]
looks so freaking painful
oh no oh no no no day Zero is back at
all of his trauma oh my God we are
standing at Ground Zero of an alien
invasion Dad how do you know about this
I need you all to evacuate now playing
here deploy all
out he's I have to make sure everyone
gets away before I deal with the ship
how are you gonna do that it's
it's oh it's literally his crib I think
Scott Glenn would make a good Paul Kent
oh even though he's been like a billion
comic things now
plastic
[Music]
training in warmth
Louis
oh no I like it like a good corn maze
yeah exactly hey
what oh
wow that's effective from a tiny shirt
from a distance yeah
thank you
oh jeez man
not bad
it's you you're the general
task force x oh Nemesis Omega zero day
next article oh those words why did you
say those words
Lois there's so much more to this
truly
[Music]
wowie the rock that hurts Clark hurts
the robots too
oh no oh no damn this is what happened
on zero day that rock is the only thing
that can destroy my ship and close the
portal it'll kill you Clark I love you
and I can't lose you oh
you too
[Music]
dude
sheeps
and again with that like lensing effect
yeah and the escalation of stakes
wow
[Music]
get out of there
still going at him whoa
[Music]
oh boy
Whoa hello
cool yes
well Kell team up yeah God when's he
gonna actually like know his name
wow that looks painful
oh
God yeah
[Music]
there that is what is happening to the
Earth's like axis right now is all these
things crash into it just another statue
next to the parasite statue
tell him
my son
oh
shot back to Earth all over again yep
same cradle
[Music]
corn feels jacked up
be the hero man
I need you to get out of the way Lois so
you can murder the man who just saved us
I am doing this to protect you Lois
that man risked everything to protect
our world let him go
General what's your situation
I'm dead
false alarm
[Music]
Dad thank you I oh Batman he definitely
knows that's Clark now right is he
pretty close pretty much recognizing
before bringing leverage's parents now
and all this still not to Temp Clark
great dinner is served
I almost didn't think we would get to
dinner you said you had something to
share I sold flame her to the Daily
Planet for 5.6 million dollars what
what
the amps please
I'm rich now pass me my damn yams
oh that's so good
oh
oh yeah
unexpected
whoa getting those dark side they have
destroyed our ships and closed our
portals
[Music]
before dark side I assume oh interesting
ha
I think I got so many questions here
what a big show this is yeah man it's a
thick boy next season Jimmy's rich
oh
out of nowhere which is something that
does happen he does come into lots of
money sometimes in the comics which is
always funny really oh yeah
this Rich history that like Rivals the
Luthers for like the Olsen's coming out
of the money and they lose it the
Luther's like there's like a rivalry if
anything else to the Luthers I love that
I I think I mean I'm not an expert by
any stretch but I love this Jimmy I I
really I still think that Alex's legs I
think that's probably that's got to be
likely and I'm glad it didn't happen
here but I think the fact that they
interviewed him and they showed him in
the last episode like sulking they cut
to him like watching the live stream
yeah and he's wearing purple yeah likes
Luther's color that's true red hair yeah
historically Lex Luthor's hair before he
loses his hair they're gonna let him
keep the hair for like three seasons
they'll get a beard like John uh what's
his name from two men and a baby or
What's that show oh prior John Craig Two
and a Half Men two and a half good men
yeah it's like two men and a baby a half
man yeah maybe yeah that's the show he
played Lex with a beer
um I enjoyed the hell out of the show
it's very good yeah I love this I I this
was like the joy of this this really
felt to me again in my more limited
experience like
a compendium of a run where like you
have very much issues but they all
amount to something which is why they
got compounded into this one unit and
yeah there's plenty more to come you
could dip in at any point and enjoy that
one episode but you know there are you
know you got your two-part event
episodes like yeah it's got a little bit
of everything that feels like a comic
it's appropriately anime in a way that I
think is really nice and fun and allows
again for the familial aspects of both
anime manga by extension and comic books
yeah uh here you know it kind of
celebrates all those things in a way
that uh coalesces in a really nice
fashion and then two it's just like a
well-told story yeah I completely agree
with your assessment of the the trade
paperback feel because it definitely
feels like two trades that are like a
part one and part two that first half we
watched kind of felt like episodes one
through four were one thing yeah and
that felt like a trade that was like you
know those issues like you said that
build to one Arc but then the second
half which was like five six seven eight
nine and ten felt like another Arc that
did go together well but you could just
grab an issue and I really like that the
tropes they use from the comics were
very approachable and the anime tropes I
was a little worried would get less
approachable
um like when they did the rocket power
stuff like that's about as like big as I
as I like sometimes like animated shows
get too big and it feels like a fox oh
yeah and like the The Sweat Beads that
anime do and then they like fall over
like this and The Sweat Beads but it was
for like moments of tension they never
had like like it walked a very fine line
that I liked they did Super restrict
because it's like I can think of at
least in these couple these three
episodes we watched today there's that
bit with Vicki Vale where they put in
like the vignetted soft focus like
that's kind of an anime thing or or here
I think at one point when they're about
to get uh when Perry's about to show
them their yep front page you know
they've got the shoulder squiggle yeah
it's like it's they borrowed yeah they
worked those cartoonish stylized anime
tropes or flourishes but yeah in like
the most restrained way possible like
it's it's just sort of the art style and
again like some of the approach to
especially like backgrounds and things
yeah you'll have like metropolis and
it's like you'll have this one layer
that's very detailed and then there's
one minute and the villains were
definitely anime yeah yeah yeah and I
think in a way that that works but that
felt more like an anime or again like
like metal gear which is yeah
like you know a lot of Japanese sci-fi
fiction uh and so yeah I I liked having
that metal gear aspect though and I
think too I I can imagine it being
something that people might debate about
like I feel like that's a choice they
made here which is you're gonna have a
bunch of uh you know one-off villains
who eventually will have to team up
under the guise of task force x I
thought that was very conscientious and
even though I'm sure it's not
everybody's favorite thing I liked what
they're going for with okay here's all
this disparate Kryptonian Tech and we
don't quite fully understand it and each
of these guys now has a different
ability because of that and it seems
like interaction with these devices rubs
off on everybody
um so you know while it's like you have
um is that black canary you know doing
the shriek and like that's not like an
organic thing and I get why some people
oh she was siren here though yeah yeah
siren um you know it's like I can
understand people not maybe loving that
that's you know a tech based thing but
for what they're doing here and for the
themes and everything and because it is
Superman I thought that was kind of a
neat and appropriate way to tie that all
together here especially because this
show doesn't feel burdened yet by having
to share with others which I really
enjoyed yeah I cut you off though are we
saying about the middle distance because
I I didn't lose my anime train I thought
with the villains but uh the animation
style foreground oh yeah you'll have
like this really detailed like when he
flies up over the city you know it's
like you'll have this detailed
foreground and then this kind of middle
detail uh layer oh and then in the back
it's just kind of like white and and you
know outlines and stuff like that and
things like that I think are are again
more toward the stylization of an anime
and when uh Clark was was trapped in
like the keeping his face vague they
like let the sadness just be shapes
which I liked it but that was a really
good way to show motion uh I like the
characterization a lot uh Lois her
lack of journalistic skill really worked
once they explained the Multiverse
because I was like really bothered by
like they're already working on the
planet but like this is not the lowest I
know and I really think that made the
whole show grow on me I think this is
one of the better use of multiverses
because not only did it improve the
show's rules it does keep things
separate and I'm then not comparing it
to like well that's not what happens
that's not like this is the character it
gives me this beautiful carte blanche to
just like enjoy the thing so I think it
does a really good job what you need in
an else world is the heart of the
character whether it's subverting that
heart or nailing it this Nails it like I
love your homelander and your Omni man
and I've talked to Ad nauseam about how
park has to be good so those characters
can exist this gets Clark so you feel
none of his his decisions feel dumb he's
not a dumb character and a lot of people
think that being nice is being dumb or
being kind is being dumb and that's why
Clark's important like the reasons
and that's why Superman is so important
is because being kind is hard and we
should look to that as a strength that
someone can be kind instead of seeing it
as a weakness I think a lot of these
fans of Superman that see kindness as a
weakness don't understand the difficulty
and the importance of kindness and they
don't understand what Superman is and
this show inherently gets Superman more
than 90 of the things I've seen of him
adapted to other mediums I was so
impressed so many lines of dialogue
obviously a lot of his actions a lot of
his decisions but they maintained this
beautiful childlike wonder that never
felt dumb they maintained this beautiful
kindness that never felt like he was
naive and the naivete that he did have
was earned by Youth and midwesternness
not dumbness yeah so impressed yeah no
absolutely I'm not saying Midwestern
people are dumb don't come at me Midwest
I'm saying the kindness that comes from
living in the town versus the city like
there's a there's an awareness of City
Life versus Town life there's no
preference there I just don't want the
certain towns to come at me I love no
shade to nobody but nobody but yeah no
he and I think they nicely embody his
his
Journey as a character like beyond all
the Superman stuff he's still just a guy
trying to make it in the big city with
his buds and crushing on a girl yeah and
and Crush was great yeah and coming of
age and going through changes and
finding out about your pet like there
are lots of layers and things like that
that you could apply to various real
life moments for people and I think uh
yeah like they never ever lost sight of
the heart while still maintaining all of
the action and stuff that you want and I
mean like you know for I'm curious as to
how the medium of Animation is going to
continue to grow and warp in our current
day and age this part of me wonders
during like I thought they did a really
nice job with the action and I thought
they did a really nice job overall
gripping with those things part of me
wonders having seen some other anime
like wow what would some of these fights
look like if they had like demon Slayers
or something like that but but I never
miss those things or even moments where
you're like ah you know this scene
they're not doing as much like mouth
movement sure um but like this the the
style and the approach and and the
spirit that they're able to conjure and
the fact too like I like in storytelling
like this I think too because it's been
so well trodden and we know so many of
the tropes uh when they really get right
to the heart of a conflict or when they
establish a conflict they go for it they
don't yeah like ah This is Gonna Come
Back nope it's happening yeah and it's
like you know we pulled the Band-Aid off
of her learning his secret identity we
pulled the Band-Aid off of um of uh the
Multiverse we pull the Band-Aid off of
all this stuff at the end with him
meeting Sam and confronting all these
circumstances and I'm really serious in
the last episode to be that big I
thought it'd be like a day new mall
because I thought we'd have like the
parasite episode and then like that'd be
our big action then the last episode
would be like and now we find out some
peace and then we go to the next season
like instead it was like we gotta have
this conflict and it was a great tease
because you have the the prospect of
Thanksgiving dinner you think well we're
gonna do something more Slice of Life
more tense at home you know more tensile
grounded scale more Clark and then yeah
yeah the Superman as so often happens
with these characters intervenes on that
and there's no choice but to go do that
stuff and I thought the way that they
wrapped all that around and then finally
came back to dinner was really nice and
and yeah you've got a solid Conflict for
Lois you called Sam from the jump Sam
Lane that was great that was a good call
and it was a I I enjoyed the build I
thought he was right about seven tenths
the way in and I was holding on to
Deadshot uh but yeah I really really
like this too I just thought it'd be
interesting to have like a guy that's
like a guy and like then you're like
whoa It's a guy that I know like he's
especially when they give him the gun I
was like what if he's really good shot
yeah but I really like the sampling
twist because then it's the Norman
Osborne thing it's the it's the uh
Adrian tombs in Spider-Man the new one
um I really enjoyed this this Show's
great uh definitely in my upper tier of
the DC animated stuff which is saying a
lot we joked earlier like they really
don't miss
um even the lower DC stuff is better
than a lot of stuff it's very good and
very loyal and these writers should
perhaps work on them again man like ever
the writers the direct like the creators
what James gun's doing I just want him
to watch this and also to be like well
we're building this whole universe live
actually maybe you guys bring some of
this stuff
because this is Superman absolutely was
absolutely is what did you think reject
Nation I enjoyed the hell out of it
hopefully and you enjoyed the heck out
of it because Superman wouldn't say hell
he's a golly gee swell boy uh please
leave a comment below let us know what
you thought of this experience let us
know what you want us to dive into next
we see you Young Justice fans we see you
and it is a maybe uh keep an eye out for
what we dive into next hit that
notification Bell hit that comment bar
hit that validation thumb and hit that
hug your family don't hit him hug them
hug them hug them hit the Instinct hit
that hit that hit that uh that
notification Bell of love and have some
Thanksgiving we're almost in the fall we
are it's Halloween in stores already I
went to Target today and it was very
Halloweenish they were moving stuff
around yeah
by the way it's almost September one no
more it's like it's Halloween no more
two weeks when September turns into
October and then Christmas what if
August is still 100 degrees but candy is
melting in the aisles bring it in I
talked to the lady at Michael's last
year I was like when's Peak Halloween
and she's like in August because we
gotta get the out of here during
October I was like ah it makes sense but
literally going to Halloween I got like
a a preview night for a haunted house on
the 7th of September not even October in
a week I'm getting spooky yeah I've
already got three of my costumes figured
out fall doesn't start to the 21st of
September not
I'm always doing it last second I got
three I got three good in the comments
let me know what you guys are being for
Halloween we love spooky season here get
after it's your lovelies we'll see you
next time
foreign